penguins joyous frolicking rattling cute
and cuddly laughs look at them
come lay onto their chubby bonbons who
could take these frisky little snow
clowns seriously does anyone even know
where we're marching to
hey anybody see that that's an A you
know we lose a few eggs every year it's
just nature
I reject nature
analysis we are really awesome at this
we've arrived in the center of Dublin
Ireland tightboys is just like Cuba well
Cuba's just like I remember it when the
world needs saving it will take the most
elite team on earth as a leader
let's go were the elitist of the elite
remain calm penguins you are now under
the protection of the north wind do you
know that you are the north wind is an
elite task force dedicated to hop it
dedicated to helping animals acock help
themselves
is it the mission we've been preparing
for our entire lives that's amusing
something chasing
snorts where hey got birdies six o'clock
yeah we
spring our trap we'll need a diversion
you're up private
we're approaching our time oh haha
whoa Hayden where's the sound day day
comes your microphone if it's not on the
button with the picture of the
microphone I'm a villain calls in this
happened hello now we can hear you but
every we cannot see how about now